nach 500 millionen us dollar
entwicklungskosten unzähligen tests und
fehlversuchen und 13 jahre nach der
ursprünglichen ankündigung war es am 6
februar 2018 endlich soweit die fältchen
heavy von spacex war bereit für ihren
allerersten testflug millionenschwere
kunden und hunderttausende fans
beobachteten ob dieses experiment
wirklich funktionieren würde
denn gründer und ceo elon musk hatte
nicht nur eine besondere fracht an bord
sondern auch vor
alle drei booster der verkehr wieder auf
der erde zu landen
[Musik]
vielen musk ist ein träumer und seine
teilweise verrückten ideen werden
regelmäßig belächelt das passierte auch
als er 2005 ankündigte raketen für
mehrere starts nutzen zu wollen
wiederverwendbare raketen die konkurrenz
reagierte darauf skeptisch bis er mit
der welt hinein ein neues kapitel in der
raumfahrtgeschichte aufschlug
zehn jahre hat es gedauert bis die
untere stufe der feld hinein nach dem
start zum ersten mal wieder auf der erde
landen konnte wie das im detail
funktioniert habe ich hier schon einmal
erklärt aber an dieser stelle noch
einmal eine zusammenfassung die feld
hinein besteht aus zwei stufen die erste
stufe ist mit neuen triebwerken
ausgestattet und sorgt während der
ersten minuten nach dem start dafür dass
die rakete an höhe und geschwindigkeit
gewinnt danach trennen sich die beiden
stufen und die zweite macht sich mit der
fracht auf dem weg in die umlaufbahn
die erste stufe hielt währenddessen
zurück zur erde und benutzt drei ihrer
triebwerke gitter flossen und landes
stützen um kontrolliert zu landen
das kann sie sowohl auf dem land als
auch auf einer schwimmenden plattform
auf dem meer
die nur ungefähr so groß wie ein
fußballfeld eine wiederverwendbare
rakete spart unglaublich viel geld
anstatt jedes mal eine komplett neue
rakete bauen zu müssen muss man diese
nur auf fehler testen und wieder mit
treibstoff auffüllen 2017 flexspace 6
erstmals erfolgreich eine feld hinein
mit einer erst stufe die bereits im all
war
dank dieses systems kann das unternehmen
flügel mit der verein für ungefähr 60
millionen dollar anbieten ein bruchteil
der konkurrenz doch maske ist dafür
bekannt sich größere ziele zu stecken
die 23 tonnen orbitale nutzlast der
fällt hinein reichen für seine vision
von zukünftigen massenszenen einfach
nicht aus genau deswegen muss jetzt eine
schwerlast rakete her
spacex kämpft ständig gegen einen großen
gegner an die hohen kosten um ins all zu
gelangen
eine neue rakete muss also möglichst
günstig entwickelt und hergestellt
werden können und was ist das einfachste
was man machen kann weil man bereits
eine rakete hat die sich teilweise
wieder verwenden lässt man aber noch
mehr leistung braucht
man nimmt einfach drei dieser raketen
und schraubt sie zusammen zack bumm
fertig ist die felton harry mehr
nutzlast mehr power und zu großen teilen
recycelbar
ein wahrer traum für jeden
größenwahnsinnigen raumfahrer gut ganz
so einfach verhält es sich mit der
feldherr wir natürlich nicht aber im
kern ist das space ex neueste kreation
die im august 2017 das erste mal das
licht der welt erblickte ganze 27
triebwerke sollen das schwergewicht
antreiben
das entspricht der schubkraft von etwa
18 boeing 747 mit dieser energie kann
die rakete 63,8 tonnen fracht von der
erde ins weltall befördern
beinahe dreimal so viel wie eine feld
hinein was auch irgendwo sinn ergibt
mit ihrer gesamtlänge von 70 metern ist
die zwei groß aber nicht die größte oder
leistungsfähigste rakete die es jemals
gab
zum vergleich die saturn 5 rakete der
nasa war ganze 110 meter hoch und konnte
zudem 133 tonnen nutzlast mitnehmen
dafür ist die fläche im heavy aber die
größte rakete die je von einem privaten
unternehmen gebaut wurde am 6 februar
2018 war es dann endlich soweit die
ganze welt schaute gespannt zum kennedy
space center maske hatte den
jungfernflug seiner riesen rakete
natürlich wie üblich gekonnt inszeniert
der presse versprach er entweder einen
großartigen start oder das größte
feuerwerk der welt und wie schon bei den
anderen staats der völker neuen gab es
einen livestream mit vielen coolen
kameraperspektiven und kommentatoren die
einem erklären fast gerade auf dem
bildschirm passiert
für den ersten testflug einer neuen
rakete ist es in der raumfahrt
normalerweise üblich ein test gewicht
anstelle einer richtigen traglast ins
all zu schicken
das risiko eines fehlschlags ist für
teure satelliten einfach zu hoch aber
einen plumpen metall klotz ins weltall
zu schießen war ihre maske dann wohl
doch zu langweilig stattdessen wurde es
ein roter tesla aus seinem eigenen
fuhrpark der von einem dummy namen
starman gefahren wird eine ausgabe von
per anhalter durch die galaxis und asi
mops foundation trilogie sind auf dem
bordcomputer des autos abgelegt worden
und damit es nicht langweilig wird sorgt
macht für die richtige musik
aus dem motto radio tönt david bowies
space oddity auch wenn im vakuum des
weltalls wohl niemand den song hören
kann
der start war in erster linie dazu
gedacht die möglichkeiten der fällt den
happy potenziellen kunden zu
demonstrieren
da darf wohl ein wenig pathos nicht
fehlen doch neben der ganzen
überspitzung wollte macht vor allem
unter beweis stellen dass die fertigen
heavy wie schon die fag hinein wieder
verwendbar ist
deshalb sollten alle drei booster
separat wieder auf der erde landen
zwei möglichst gleichzeitig an land und
der dritte auf einer plattform auf dem
meer
[Applaus]
der start verlief einwandfrei doch die
zitterpartie sollte noch weiter gehen
ganze acht minuten mussten wir warten
bis die ersten teile 2 booster die
auszeit kurz genannt werden wieder in
cape canaveral landeten und was für ein
bild beinahe perfekt landen zwei raketen
synchron nebeneinander
wenn man bisher noch nicht das gefühl
hatte in der zukunft zu leben dann
sollte sich dieses gefühl jetzt
eingestellt haben
es fehlte nur noch ein teil um den
hattrick perfekt zu machen
der mittelteil der ersten stufe oder
auch der center chor doch bei ihm lief
es leider nicht ganz so wie geplant
nachdem dieser den tesla roadster noch
ein stück weiter gebracht und sich dann
von ihm getrennt hatte sollte auch er
unbeschadet wieder auf der erde landen
leider reaktivierte sich nur einer der
booster und anstatt sanft und präzise
auf einer schwimmenden plattformen im
ozean zu landen verfehlte der center
quasi um 100 meter und schlug mit rund
500 km h aus wasser auf auch mit dem
tesla gab es probleme
nach seinem abwurf flug er zunächst wie
geplante sechs stunden durch
danach sollte der roadster mit hilfe von
einer weiteren raketen zündung in eine
elliptische bahn um die sonne befördert
werden
und natürlich sollte diese auch am mars
vorbei führen
allerdings ist die obere stufe mit der
nutzlast über die geplante flug bahn
hinaus geflogen und der roadster
befindet sich jetzt in einem ägyptischen
orbit um die sonne bei dem er zwischen
den entfernungen des mars und der erde
hin und her pendelt aber schöne autos im
weltall hin oder her
spacex ist ein business und am ende des
tages muss es geld verdienen
ziehen wir also einmal den vergleich die
nun zweitgrößte aktive rakete delta her
wie vor vom konkurrenten united launch
alliance kann etwas mehr als 28 tonnen
nutzlast aufnehmen
spacex hat für die entwicklung der fake
in heavy 500 millionen us dollar gezahlt
der konkurrent kostete dagegen stolze 27
5 milliarden dollar ea kann also nur die
hälfte des gewichts transportieren
zahlte dafür aber in der entwicklung das
fünffache dazu muss man natürlich
erwähnen dass basics die basis der
fakten her wie bereits im voraus zur
verfügung hatte schließlich wird die
felgen ein schon seit jahren produziert
die kostenersparnisse bei der produktion
und die potentielle wiederverwendung
lassen sich aber nicht leugnen
denn für einen staat defekten heavy
zahlen kunden ungefähr 90 millionen us
dollar das sind 310 millionen dollar
weniger als der nächstbeste konkurrent
von spacex verlangt einen spottpreis
und wenn wir das einmal mit der saturn 5
der nasa vergleichen dann machen sich
die ersparnisse erst recht bemerkbar
ein staat der saturn 5 kostete damals
das 13 fache eines heutigen stars
defekten harry ob die fällt im heavy
allerdings der richtige strategische zug
für spacex war das wird sich noch zeigen
denn die entwicklungen der blick fällt
im rocket laufen auf hochtouren
die nur wenigen jahren könnte die fällt
im heavy schon von einer noch größeren
rakete abgelöst werden
das könnte sogar so bald passieren dass
basics bereits angekündigt hat die fake
in heavy nicht für bemannte flüge
vorzubereiten
stattdessen übernimmt die kleinere feld
hinein die ersten bemannten missionen
zur internationalen raumstation bis die
bfa in den startlöchern steht
trotz aller probleme kann man allerdings
eines festhalten maske hat unter beweis
gestellt dass seine technik auch in
größeren dimensionen funktionieren kann
und dass etwas von marketing versteht
das wussten wir ja schon länger
[Musik]